[Music]
hey there my name is ben and i was just
playing a little song i wrote for a
peanuts earth day special called it's
the small things charlie brown
it's about friendship coming together
and taking care of the place we call
home
i was wondering would you like to learn
a bit of the song yay
great okay let's look at the melody here
it's the small things
simple that is a g
a
b
back to g
so you can do these three fingers if you
want
[Music]
or
[Music]
it's the small things
you know when i was writing this song
something funny occurred to me the show
is all about small things coming
together to make something greater then
it really made me think of music and
songs because that's exactly how they
work notes coming together to make
chords and melodies small things
becoming big things and that thought is
going to take us right into the next
part all right let's see what you got we
come together to make big things
that's a few more notes so maybe you
want to lay your hands like this see
that you can start with an e so
we come together
to make big things if you don't get it
the first time
don't worry about it
perhaps you should try a different
approach you can go back and try again
as much as you want to that's what we
call practice now if you don't have a
piano
that's no problem you can be the
percussionist which is what i was when i
was growing up
and percussionist is the person who
pounds on things to keep the beat or the
rhythm of the song now there are all
kinds of percussion instruments i used
to use basketballs and coffee cans
because i didn't have a drum set but you
can snap clap
whatever you want to do now when the
music starts just tap along with the
beat
i'm going to use this tambourine right
here
hit it
[Music]
that's great you're doing great we
really found our groove
now i don't know about you but i can't
wait to watch it's a small things
charlie brown i think you're gonna love
it
you